foreign
[Music]
Cassie
oh no
[Music]
okay I have a suit yeah I noticed
you okay yes
look momentum right jump tap right one
move jump tap I know how to do it dad oh
do you yes really because it didn't look
like it from my end I messed up on the
timing
like that you see what I did you see
what I did no you're like this small I
jumped into half
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time like me
we could help each other with that
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
can give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
this is all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
thank you
[Music]